give me a wonderful opening because you
asked if spectrograph metals can be
applied to networks so here they are and
it's interesting that this has been a
recurring theme in this workshop this
must be like I don't know the fifth or
sixth talk about network propagation or
other types of sort of extracting
information from a network in a global
manner not really what I like to do is
to convince you that this is really
although it's quite simple or
straightforward people may say this is
really a powerful tool for extracting
information so it should probably tunity
and the type of problems i'm going to
look at our what we call guilt by
association and again it ties to the
previous talk where we have some partial
information on a process we are
interested in in the case of this talk
it's going to be about disease but it
could be for example in function
prediction it could be about a specific
function and really our goal is to try
to enrich this information so to score
the remaining genes for the relation to
this process or disease in question and
of course you can think about very
immediate methods that people have been
used a lot using a lot for achieving
these goals for example you can simply
for every protein count how many
interactions does it have to the non
protein so this is what is called the
neighborhood counting method or the
majority method you can compute the
average distance of a protein to the
known proteins you can even go and
compute a hyper geometric p value but
all these methods have discovered that
they are local so they look at the local
neighborhood of a protein and we and
others i found out that you have much
more power if you try to look globally
at the network and so network
propagation i won't give a lot of
introduction because so much has been
told about it but let me just give you a
visual overview of how it works so you
have some problem information and then
you also have the protein interaction
network and now you do the following
iterative process each iteration you
pump information of flow from this prior
to the nodes and in parallel every node
pumps flow to its neighboring nodes and
you let this process converge and when
it converged you are sure that the
scored that you are viewing to a node is
a sum of two terms that reflect two very
desirable properties one is the disco is
smooth over the network so it means that
the scope and all these more or less the
average of disco of its neighbors and on
the other hand it also accounts for your
prior information there is this delicate
parameter that we'll talk about that
balances how much you believe the
network versus how much you believe
you're firing from issue and so
propagation has been used a lot in
network biology over the past few days I
learned a few references I even didn't
know so in function prediction we heard
the talk bye Lenore in gene disease
association in a pathway disease
associations of the hotness etc and
disease classification and I probably
missed a bunch of a other references so
what I'd like to tell you about today
are two stories recently from my lab
that have to do is using network
propagation to understand disease the
first one will be about finding driver
genes in cancer and the second one will
be about finding disease modules in
general for any disease so stuck with
the first one this is a collaboration
with a minute craters group and MIT
sitting here and the main auto is a
metal follow so the motivation for this
work and again Ben has given a lot of
motivation about it previously as well
as fabio is that when we measure for
example by these cancer consortium when
we measure information about two more
samples we have two problems one of them
is that we are whatever we are measuring
is of only
a very partial a picture of what is
going on and they mentioned this long
tail problem and the other problem that
we have is that we are measuring we
could measure different snapshots of
different processes that are taking part
in the cell but so for example we
measure some upstream events in the form
of mutations and some downstream events
in the form of a differentially
expressed genes but we are not observing
things that are going on in the middle
and so our goal would be to integrate
all the valuable information in order to
learn new nodes in the middle that are
involved in cancer and so what you could
do and people have been doing is for
example to look at mutations and to
average them across samples and then get
a score for a gene which will maybe
indicate it is moment in cancer but
again we have this long tail problem so
instead what we are proposing to do and
we'll check that in a minute is to
propagate this information in the
network and now average DS and now get
perhaps elite your picture of what is
going on and similar we could do for
differential expression so instead of
taking the whole differential expression
values we could propagate them first in
the network and then look at the
information this is obtained so
amazingly when you do that and I'll show
you two data sets for which we have done
that so this one is breast cancer you
get an immense boosting performance okay
so for example if you look at how well
are you recapitulating known breast
cancer genes as taken from the NCBI
pathway by just looking at the frequent
at the frequency in which they are
mutated then you get this mediocre occur
however when you first propagate this
information in the network suddenly you
get a boost of about point two in their
performance and similar goals similarly
it goes for differential expression
so if you just take a differential
expression as is you don't get much the
minute you propagate it in the network
you boost your performance and again
this can be reproduced in another data
set and these are the two months that we
tried and this one is glioblastoma yes
so the in terms of cancer gene discovery
some of the genes were discovered using
networks so by propagation on that works
as well so the so of course it's very
hard to handle these biases are we are
going to show you know to validation
sets and of course you can argue that
everything we are doing is biased by
experimentation by people studying
certain genes are so so I don't know how
to respond to that beyond this is your
interrupted if I just one quick question
so mutations are sparse or propagation
has a good rationale for differential
expression are you talking about
propagating some sort of p value or
something that's discreet because
expression is continuous and measured so
it's a good question so in this work
what we did was simply for every sample
simply record whether a gene was
differentially expressed or not so this
is binary and then you propagate those
and same goes for mutations so mutation
frequency
is the number of mutations or is it
correctly so as far as i remember we
simply took the frequency aziz we did
not call it for me and you don't you
don't care about co-occurrences
nothing this were not not yet what's the
network name I do you remember which
network we use oh so we use GP so this
is like 100 so it's 150,000 interactions
and it was called by our collaborators I
will mention them in the second world
can based on the experimentation so to
continue so now that I did should be
very very clear to you we take the raw
data binary we propagate it in the
network so for every sample we simply
propagate the mutation or the gene
expression data and now we have
propagated matrices and from the is
propagated matrices we now would like to
find feature that will help us predict
new cancer genes okay so what could
these features be they could simply talk
as people have done in the past about
the frequency of the mutation they could
talk about the frequency sorry about the
mean a score of the propagation they
could talk about the voyance they could
talk about the correlation between gene
expression propagation and mutation
propagation and they could talk about
the minimum propagation value that we
get from Bose to all the maximum okay so
these are the kinds of features and when
we apply those features so we now learn
so we train a logistic regression we
either do feature a selection or we
don't and when we apply this classifier
these are the locals that we get so
first of all with respect to the known
pathway so this is the NCBI pathway for
glioblastoma we took the kegg pathway
and this is an auto ganar validation set
we simply check how well are we
performing oh well are we reproducing
the cancer gene sensors
okay so maybe it answer is your question
maybe not and then we we can ask
ourselves how much did we learn from
mutations versus expression so we find
out that at least in the two data sets
that we tried mutations perform a
somewhat better than expression but the
combined model has some still some game
as opposed to each one of them so we do
gain something by integrating both
mutation and expression and in fact when
we look who is the top performing
feature that gives us the best
classification performance it is the
minimum propagation scope so if you look
at the gene you ask yourself what is its
minimum propagation score between
propagating the mutations and
propagating the expression so if you
take the minimum how proximal is it to
both of them this is what gives the most
power and so you could ask yourself well
you said there was one parameter in your
method so it's a very simple metal but
still it has one parameter you could ask
yourself how about are your results to
this parameter and it turns out that the
results are pretty robust so you can see
the curves here so this is the AUC as a
function of the parameter going from 0
to 1 and you can see that no more or
less the results are the same and now
the last thing that we did in this story
we wanted to see beyond anecdotal
examples where we go in the literature
and look at the genes that we predict
are they really known to be involved in
cancer or not we wanted to see whether
we could use those genes to see some
significant change in survival between
patients that have mutations or
differential expression in these genes
versus patients that done so what you
see here are the p-values or the minus
log P values of the log-rank test both
for mutation which appears even read
then for gene expression which appears
in blue and what you see are the top 25
genes that were ranked by our classifier
and we're not included in the respective
and no Patrick's and it's actually as I
guess iono just us it's actually quite
arbitrary those pathways and of course
the knowledge keeps evolving so for
example when you look at this 25 genes
immediately you observe this grip to
here which is both significant and is
very well known to be involved in
meeting us breast cancer so I don't know
why was not included in the NCBI data
set but nevertheless it's quite
reassuring to see that the metal picked
it up oh yes what data this is a TCG how
many CGA how many samples I don't know
hundreds i don't remember the exact
number maybe 300 here and 500 year or
900 e i'm not sure he keeps changing the
question I guess is at which point it is
2014 we downloaded the data type 2014
thanks for change what is it so
surprising
does it not matter at all it's a good
question you do see some right some rise
in the beginning but i agree i guess
that so we didn't start at 0 of course
we do some propagation i guess that it
only tells you that the minute you put
some of the network inside you already
see a boost in performance I cannot
comment beyond that yeah it just it's a
balance between the prior knowledge that
you use sorry it's a balance between the
pile knowledge that you use and then in
the network and the smoothness of the
network let me try to go back maybe it
wasn't him so here is the parameter okay
it doesn't fit your comparison of the
auc curves right way you see these
differences right but when I see these
differences it's when not doing
propagation at all right when taking
when taking the frequency values as as
they are once you do some propagation
then obviously you you need is the
extreme point of alpha 0 but I didn't
have the extreme points so we never used
a value of zero right so the care of
started zero point something
yes so to summarize this part what I try
to show you is that propagation can help
you to enrich your information to extend
your information between beyond the
limited prior knowledge and also for
this specific application we do see some
some boost in performance when
integrating both types of information
usually in most words that i know of
people have been looking mutations we do
think that gene expression can can also
inform the prediction process and so let
me now switch gears to the other work
yes before too before you switch to the
other work in the top 25 genes that you
report do you see genes that are not
mutated nor differentially expressed at
all I don't think we looked at it so I
don't know the answer the internship the
integration that
you over but if you already stopped me
let me let me take a look actually I do
have a so just by the fact that there is
some p value here i guess that all of
them had some a mutation or gene
expression in n in one of the samples
yes you talked about yes so you have so
we have overall something like 13
features so about half of them come from
expression or sorry maybe once or come
from expression one-third come from
mutation and one-third come from the
correlation between the two and we do
see that when you use mutation features
only or expression features only we see
some performance when we use balls it
goes a bit higher not for the survive
for the walkers right so this was here
this was this part right so these are
mutations only these this is expression
only in these are bows
now the integration is the classifier is
doing the integration right it depends
whether you apply ok sorry boss by
integration I just hope the chair
counted on the Q&A so you show us the
sparse and say that books are babies
watching supposed to the Sun force our
backyard cricket understand that
combined expansion but what if i
understand correctly and use expressions
that we really and because a special
will pick some of some of the gains
mutational pics and other things i will
can present some from those independent
it versus combine them try but at the
end you have to give one score for a
gene so that you can do a little curve
the best way I know of doing that is to
apply classifier right the classifier
ways them for you right so this is
exactly what we did surprise didn't have
more
yeah but you know remember that we are
already in the point 8 regime or the
point 9 regime so how much more can it
go okay this is a question that I asked
during our discussion how so you start a
signal is the frequency of a particular
mutation in this covertly like we take a
pair sample we simply take a binary
signal whether it was mutated or not I
see so you're doing it for patient right
we do that let me go back and show since
I go this promise of 15 more minutes you
know
I love it
or something is oh this one right so
what we do is for example we propagating
the network and now we have per sample
the propagated matrix okay so these are
rose each one is sample and same goes
here so we do a very simple operation
right we take the gold Ireta we
propagate it in the network now we have
new vectors and now we operate on those
just stay thirsty it's random walk with
restart we had these very very long
discussions about what is the difference
between propagation and diffusion and
random walks everything is the same so
you know actually I must I must confess
you know yesterday when I said to
prepare for this talk I thought maybe I
should in the title simply use a smaller
font for the word propagation because
it's not really about propagation it's
about some automatic way of taking into
account the entire network when making
your predictions name right and you know
I call it network application you can
call it diffusion actually you called it
reverse engineering maybe I don't know
it will make two points one I will
instead Fabio's question right so far
this question was among the 25 that you
showed whether there was anything but it
wasn't differentially expressed or
mutated in any of the samples we
actually looked at that right because
I'll it's one of our goals really and
among those 25 there are none so there
were none [ __ ] verge correlated with
patient outcome but we do take the top
10 that were differentially expressed
all mutated in any of the samples but
verse court I that's and among those ten
nine of them had some relationship to
some cancer so that was I mean it was a
kind of leak meditation but I think I
think it was an
validation and then I may also tell what
I understand is the difference between a
propagation nurses Randolph it restarts
and in between these two these two are
very similar writing different diffusion
models network propagation norm is
normalized according to both being
coming and out going fruit slaw where is
random walk it restarts on the normal is
according to our point so network
propagation is a little more robust to
degree by us so then the walk with the
Stars is usually it tends to score the
hub's more than it should nipple
propagation corrects it for that to a
certain extent it's what I understand I
mean you can change ending that your
agenda walk okay so switching gears to
the second world so the second work is
about finding disease modules again
using network propagation and this is
joint with my longtime collaborator
erich von kale was actually the advisor
of julio spoke earlier today a and
conrad clock mile from his lab in berlin
and so we know that many diseases are
actually the result not from the
dysregulation of a single gene but
rather from the dysregulation of
complexes for some reason there are not
a whole lot of methods they try to infer
those disease modules or complexes
rather people have been mainly focusing
on prioritizing single genes however we
have previously worked out this metal
that is called Prince to identify
disease-related complexes and maybe you
can think of using hot neck 20 hot net
as a way of getting both complexes and
passwords or let's simply call them
disease modules for diseases although
night to was designed specifically for
cancer you'll see that here we try to
adapt it to the setting that we've been
using so both these methods what
essentially they do they start with a
protein-protein touch network and with
no disease-causing proteins then they
propagate this information of
disease-causing proteins in the network
they pick some threshold this threshold
lets them zoom in on the regions of the
network that are interesting for the
disease and once you zoom in on these
regions of the network you try to use
your plastic method your favorite
testing method in order to find really
complexes or clusters inordinate to its
strongly connected components in Prince
it is something that will be very
similar to what i will show next finding
the dense complexes and in this work
that i'll present today what we actually
identified our sort of to intervention
points two points that we thought could
be improved in previous work so one of
them was how do you choose this
threshold can you choose this threshold
in a statistical manner even promoting
things that are maybe here but in fact
are statistically significant and
removing things that maybe are high up
here but are not statistically
significant and the second thing we try
to improve is the finding of a dense
clusters so previously it was done using
some greedy approach and we wanted to
see what is the contribution of an
optimal ILP approach to this problem so
let's start with the first thing which
is how do you choose a threshold for
network propagation so if you just do
network propagation then your scores
really depend on the size of the prior
information so if the side of the prior
information is 10 this is the
distribution that you get for
propagation scores if it goes to 25
suddenly you'll see it's a bit higher if
you go to 100 it's a lot higher so it
means they
when you are now going to operate on
different diseases with different
prioritizes you cannot simply say I'll
take a cut off of point2 and hope that
it will catch the real biology so we
make a very simple but yet a powerful
suggestion we simply say let's normalize
our propagation scores by comparing them
to what would happen if you take if you
took land umpires of the same size so we
simply compute empirical p values for
propagation scores and now we can simply
take a cut-off 4.05 or point zero one
and we know that what's above it is
significant what's below it is not not
significant so this is one contribution
the others contribution is about finding
dense clusters so the way we score
clusters is using a likelihood ratio
test which I talked about in the boot
camp so essentially we assume that in a
protein complex every interaction should
be present with some high probability on
the other hand our way Lando model is of
a degree preserving graph we can also
estimate the probability of an edge it's
the product of the degrees of the nodes
over two times the number of edges and
so we can compute for any suggestion of
a complex we can compute its likelihood
score which factors over the edges and
and edges of this complex and since this
call is essentially linear if you take a
log transformation we can actually write
quite easily down an ILP that solves it
to optimality so really gives you the
top scorer in clusters so you don't need
the greedy algorithm anymore you can
really on these networks using the
propagation really zooms you in on the
the region that it rests you you can
apply a full-scale ILP and just solve it
to optimality
humans I mean you could say that but
people before human of course realized
that you can estimate these
probabilities yeah it's just the they
given degree sequence Randall model okay
so the data sets we applied the Darrell
going Tim to eat always follow so first
of all we took a disease associations
from three databases so we had about
sorry we had about 8,000 associations
for 100 diseases and again we use the
hippie network from Eric bunker and so
to evaluate how we are doing we simply
applied each one of the method so we had
our new method the old prints and hot
need to and we adapted hot neck to to
the scenario if you are interested in
the common area I could say something
about it we simply checked how enrich
where our predictions with known
complexes in the in the databases so we
use the a14 complexes from the gene
ontology and from the cone database and
so what you see in these plots are the
number of clusters each method predicted
and what percent of these clusters will
actually enriched so for our method let
me read from the screen for our method
it was about fifty percent for prints it
was about thirty six percent and for hot
net it was about thirty percent okay and
you can see that and the number of
predictions varies a bit but all of them
are in the hundreds
so now to further validate their
predictions what we could do we could
use information that we didn't use in
our priors because it was considered
less reliable from the disease's
database we didn't use text mining
associations and experimental
associations so we could use these
associations in order to again see
whether the genes were we were
predicting for a given disease as part
of the complexes were actually known to
be related to this disease so again we
quantify that using a hyper geometric
score and we could see that our
algorithm captured significantly 34
diseases twins captured a very similar
number while for hot neck too
unfortunately i don't know why only two
of the of the disease only two of the
diseases we saw a significant overlap so
the the last validation that we did was
to try to see whether we can boost so so
of course in these validations the
problem was that the validation sets
were limited in scope and so the
question was whether we can further
validate our our predictions by using
information from similar diseases so the
idea is as follows suppose I'm
predicting several genes for a given
disease a and I don't really know
whether they belong to this disease or
not then what I can see is whether they
are known to be associated with similar
diseases and i can define my success as
they best similarity each one of those
jeans attains to a similar disease so
the bet the most similar disease to
which each one of those genes is known
to be associated average over the genes
in my predictions and so we get the
distributions of scores
for all diseases and we can again
compare this distribution over the three
methods and what we see again is that
the performance of prints and our new
method a relatively similar but a
significantly higher than the
performance a whole fortnight to and it
could be related also to the previous
validation and so just two ND story with
one specific example here is a cluster
that we predicted for epilepsy this is
the top predicted cluster in this case
we had 97 pyogenes and disappear is
diamond so in this specific complex that
we predicted three genes were known and
then four were predicted interestingly
out of these 4 30 calmodulin a coding
genes and a one is a another gene and it
turned out from the literature that for
both predictions they are modeling in
the casing and q5 both predictions were
supported by the literature so to
summarize this part I try to show you
that propagation can be successfully
used to zoom in on interesting regions
in the network that are related to
disease I've shown you that the
resulting clustering problem can be
actually soft to optimality using
integer linear programming and let me
just end by saying that one thing we
didn't use in this prediction algorithm
is the fact that we can pull information
for sim from similar diseases in order
to enrich our knowledge about the
disease we are trying to predict so we
just submitted a paper which tries to
harness this information and in fact to
predict simultaneously for all diseases
the modules in a way that will maximize
the correlation between the predictions
and what we know about the similarity of
these diseases so with that I'll end
this is my group these are my
collaborators that I already mentioned
and
for those of you who never tried and are
interested and only is the living proof
for that we do have a cytoscape plug-in
which is called propagate which you can
download from this cytoscape app store
and simply try it in your favorite
application thank you when you do this
validation by literature search thanks
have you ever given people a randomized
that's a good approach to he direct your
questions to some other speaker I so we
didn't try that yeah sorry very works
also we gave listed i think it was 17
this was disease disease association so
i gave 17 disease disease associations
they came out of our method as well as
random disease disease associations to
someone at that point
go to pubmed and say there's strong meat
or no evidence in pubmed of this
association so they went it did that and
then we got the list back and then
pulled out which ones were random with
our method and then we compared and for
our method at least we got more
struggles expected so there can be a
sensitivity difference are you were
suggested it sweet hit it worked out
nicely so I see the biological rationale
for propagating the gene expression but
what's the reasoning we are unprofitable
the notation the patient's are discrete
events so it's very simple if you
believe you know all the evidence that
we saw in the past few days then cancer
is a disease of pathways mutations
targets different genes in the same
pathway for example you see a different
mutation if you propagate then maybe you
are able to really pin down the pathway
what you would get suppose that you end
up with one gene that is never mutated
and yet the propagation hits it all the
time would you call it a tragar I would
argue not but it is one I would argue
yes driver pathway right that's exactly
well if you're going for the pathway yes
but for the first part of 12 you're
targeting genes but but but chengdu you
have this empirical information whether
genes that were I don't know reported in
keg as belonging to a certain cancer
will actually seen mutated in that
cancer so do you have this empirical
information I bet that there are some
genes the in known databases that we
will agree on that we're never seen to
be mutated or maybe differentially
expressed so we obviously couldn't I
mean maybe it's
meet of the data right maybe when you
have millions of samples you'll see
everything but I don't know the question
is if you have if you can converge on a
gene which has never been observed as
mutated in a patient or significantly
differentially expressed in a patient I
would argue it's a property of an
algorithm identified it or it's not just
you what it means to me is that there is
no evidence in the patients that have
been seen that this is actually but so
let me comment also about that of course
if you saw in one sample that the gene
was mutated or differentially expressed
you will never call it a driver G right
so we talked a lot about this long tail
problem so I'm saying is that network
propagation can help you to boost the
signal so even though it was may be
observed in one or two samples because
it's part of a pathway and because some
other genes were observed you might
boost its core so this is all I'm
claiming i'm not saying you know now
trying to argue about data yes i'm not
surprised that some of the more
sophisticated methods um didn't do with
partner to and whatever performed [ __ ]
we saw something similar when we tried
it in women
talk about on Monday and I think part of
it is also that when people try to go to
the wet lab and test diseases to be
associated with jeans um maybe they are
also doing guilt by association to
decide what's attacked and so the set of
genes that have been tested for diseases
are very biased toward finding local um
samples so I think that bias is in the
data which makes validation very very
hard when you're doing something that's
more global so when you find something
more surprising you are coming up with
short of the first evidence that would
ask the wet lab person to spend time in
moreno valley so I mean it's not
surprising to me that the data of what
we actually know is biased towards the
things that are that are nearby that's
so to follow up on that as mammatus just
reminded me we did look at those jeans
that were not mutated or differentially
expressed and we could find evidence for
them even though you would never spot
them you know when you look at the whole
data so these global methods can
sometimes identify things that are yeah
I'm just I'm just as somebody who's a
big advocate as your methods um I think
it's really hard to find unbiased sets
to validate that we're actually anything
that we all like worried
here you show that some kind of staple
my basic opinion is this is really
data-dependent to me the Alpha value is
there you could let's say the chastity
and the you for the X gene expression is
noisy that the network of our debate
should be higher and I have been
struggling um there's how best we keep
cessation or do is they actually and
this is what I'm trying to look but I
don't know if I'll find that actually
our experience has been different so at
least in the range of let's see where
one of my paper is my experience I don't
know I cannot see it now but at least in
the original prints paper where we first
used this metro propagation method we
also work quite hard at looking into how
stable the results were two to the Alpha
parameter and there we saw that at least
from the range from point 52.9 the
results were basically the same so
whenever you introduce enough of the
network so so at least that that has
been our and I and I invite you we
thought that we might try to you know to
take all these approaches and I know
that you wrote a survey about them we
will try to take all these approaches
and agree on some standardized data and
and you know just test them so that we
can all believe you know what we are
doing so you know I invite you to
participate in this
yeah I gene that agent guy they say okay
so choose 22 or something like that
that's where offer to buy fire that's
what's the I um got it I mean I struck
me with myself all right